the explosion at this ammunition depot
was initially considered an accident
but czech authorities now suspect russia
over the 2014 blast which left two
workers dead
they're looking for these men who were
in the country at the time
under the aliases alexander petrov and
ruslan boshirov
allegedly part of a gru military
intelligence unit
called 29155 they're the same men
accused by the uk over the salisbury spy
poisonings
outraged the czech republic is expelling
18
russian diplomats
i decided to deport all workers of the
russian embassy in prague
who were clearly identified by our
secret service as members of the russian
secret service
the svr and the gru britain's foreign
secretary
supported the move in response to what
he called
russia's dangerous and malign operations
critical words alone not enough for some
this is a direct attack on a nato
country this is the murder
of two czech systems in a uh weapons
establishment so if that isn't a
war-like act frankly i have
very difficult in knowing what one is uh
so i think we need to be
dealing with russia in the way that it
deals with the rest of the world which
is
harshly unit 29155
is of significant interest to western
security services
some members are believed to have taken
part in russia's 2014
annexation of crimea the unit has also
been linked with the poisoning
of bulgarian arms dealer emilian gabrev
in 2015 a failed coup in montenegro the
following year
the novichok attack against sergey and
yulia skripal in salisbury
and last year reports emerged of the
unit
allegedly offering bounties to afghan
militants
for killing nato troops the bulgarian
arms dealer
could be why this czech depot was hit
on exactly the day that um that the
explosion took place there was a
transaction closing
in fact the loading of weapons or
ammunition to
um to depart to bulgaria exactly being
acquired by emily and gabriel was was
taking place
so it seems that that particular
transaction or that particular
inventory was being targeted a recent
build up
of russian forces on its border with
ukraine
is already increasing tensions between
russia and the west
new czech allegations met with a denial
from moscow
and a promise to retaliate european
union foreign ministers
set to discuss the matter on monday
debra haynes sky news